last night I went to go see Five Nights
at Freddy's in theaters and it was one
of the better theater-going experiences
a movie can be really fun when the crowd
is into it and I haven't seen an
audience with this much energy in years
and it wasn't in an annoying way there
was tension during the suspense scenes
there was Buzz for all the FNAF Easter
eggs and there was just a shared sense
of delight when we saw the cameos from
Matt Pat and Cory Kenshin and then the
end credits hit and you hear the living
tombstone's iconic Five Nights at
Freddy's song and the theater was just
jamming okay I almost always stay to the
end of the credits and usually I'm the
last one to leave but for this almost
everyone stayed and then the lights went
on and were still not leaving I've
honestly never seen anything like it